do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes as amber heard appeals the
verdict in johnny depp's defamation
trial case against her she's hiring new
lawyers to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony as for johnny
he's busy getting back to work i've
gained some degree of success in this
industry i mean i'm really it's it's
been it's been very it's been very good
to me and it's been very good for me but
first amber's legal team shakeup the
actress is now represented by david l
axelrod and j ward brown her lead
appellate counsel they shared in a joint
statement quote we welcome the
opportunity to represent ms hurd in this
appeal as it is a case with important
first amendment implications for every
american as for her previous team ben
rottenborn will continue to represent
amber as co-counsel but elaine bredhoft
she's stepping down and how is she today
what is that what is her next move she's
right well her next move is appeal there
was a heartbroken she is heartbroken and
one of the first things that she said
when she came back from the verdict when
we went into the conference room was i
am so sorry to all these women that's
elaine back in june revealing amber's
decision to appeal the jury's decision
which found that she did defame johnny
do you feel like you could be sued again
by him for defamation i'm scared
that
no matter what i do
no matter what i say or how i say it
um every step that i take
will present another opportunity
for
this sort of uh silencing
which is what i guess a defamation
lawsuit is meant to do it's meant to
to take your voice and while amber
continues to fight back johnny's
focusing on his career on the big screen
and behind the camera for the actor's
first feature film role in three years
he's making a royal return as king louis
xv in the new period drama john dubari
that's the first glimpse of johnny fully
clad as the 1700s era monarch find out
where
where you want to be
you know and uh and get there i just
started you know
taking steps forward and finding my road
you know and that road also includes
directing keeping with the period piece
theme johnny will direct modi a biopic
about 18th century italian artist amadeo
modigliani and get this it's johnny's
first time behind the lens in 25 years
the last time he directed a project was
1997's the brave which johnny also
starred in alongside hollywood legend
marlon brando tell me
are you afraid to die
are you
shortly after the verdict was announced
a source told e.t johnny's looking
forward to reclaiming his place in
hollywood quote he feels like things are
on the upswing for him and like he
cleared his name he's looking forward to
the future both personally and
professionally and feels like he got his
career back
[Music]
you